en los vídeos pasados hemos aproximado
áreas por debajo de la gráfica de una
función utilizando rectángulos donde el
alto estaba dado por la función evaluada
en el extremo izquierdo entonces
teníamos rectángulos más o menos de esta
forma para
aquí teníamos un primer rectángulo que
llegaba como por acá y entonces el
rectángulo se veía así
es hoy ayer era nuestro rectángulo
número 1 luego en nuestro segundo
rectángulo empezaba en x 1 su altura era
f x 1 y que teníamos algo de este estilo
más o menos algo así luego el tercer
rectángulo que es el segundo el tercer
rectángulo su altura era fx2 más o menos
en este punto tenemos fx2 ba y seguíamos
seguíamos y seguíamos hasta llegar al
enésimo rectángulo donde la altura era
fx n 1 que pereció en el -1 o sea llegar
hasta aquí
y la base era un cierto delta xv ah
entonces este de aquí es el enésimo
rectángulo ok entonces cuando
realizábamos la suma de estas áreas que
nos quedaba pues la aproximación nos
quedaba la suma la suma desde y igual a
1 hasta n esto lo que indicaba era que
nos fuéramos moviendo en cada uno de los
rectángulos desde el primero hasta el
enésimo de qué cosas pues de las áreas
de estos rectángulos y el área estaba
dada por la altura la altura que era f
de x menos 1 multiplicada por un delta x
aquí fx y menos 1 hace que corresponda
con lo que queremos verdad sí
-es 1 nos queda el primer rectángulo y
que de fede x 0 si es 2 es el segundo
rectángulo queda efe x 1 y así si
llegamos hasta n el enésimo rectángulo
tiene altura
fx n 1 entonces esas son las alturas y
estoy acá el delta x era el largo y como
estábamos suponiendo que todos los
rectángulos tenían el mismo largo que
ese largo lo podríamos calcular
considerando la longitud del intervalo
que era ver - y dividiendo entre la
cantidad de rectángulos que era n muy
bien entonces esto de acá nos da una
aproximación sin embargo debes estar
pensando que no es la única forma de
aproximar el área y si tienes toda la
razón en realidad podemos aproximar
evaluando la función no en electro mi
izquierda sino en el derecho o en el
punto medio o incluso podemos utilizar
otra figura geométrica entonces vamos a
ver eso en estas otras figuras en estas
otras gráficas de por acá vale vamos a
estar acá ya la de la derecha y vamos a
pensar que aquí esté los rectángulos la
altura está dada por efe por la función
evaluado en el extremo derecho entonces
ahora nuestro primer rectángulo tendría
esta altura va tendría esta altura de
acá entonces ahora sería un rectángulo
un poco más chaparrito que antes ese de
ahí sería el primer rectángulo el
segundo rectángulo ahora tendría esta
altura de acá esta verdad
efe evaluada en x2 déjalo déjalo
efe
este es de la cacería efe en x 1 creo
que esto no se ve mucho pero bueno se ve
la idea verdad y así así vamos a
continuar hasta el enésimo rectángulo y
ahora la altura estaría dada por fx en
sí entonces este de acá sería el enésimo
el enésimo rectángulo
muy bien ahora como nos quedaría nuestra
aproximación cómo quedaría la suma pues
una vez más va a ser la suma
otra vez tenemos que movernos por n
rectángulos entonces vamos desde igual a
uno hasta n vamos recorriendo todos del
área y ahora cuál es la altura pues la
altura ahora digamos para el primer
rectángulo es f x 1 para el segundo s f
de x2 entonces ahora no quedaría efe de
x y multiplicado x el largo que es delta
x este delta x es el mismísimo delta x
que antes y eso no ha cambiado lo que sí
cambia la diferencia con el anterior es
que antes la altura estaba dada por efe
en el extremo izquierdo pero ahora la
altura está dada por efe en el extremo
derecho vale muy bien ahora qué tal que
no queremos aproximar utilizando la
función evaluada en los extremos sino
que queremos evaluar la función en el
punto medio vamos a ver cómo nos
quedarían las cuentitas pasando a esta
figura de acá entonces ahora ahora el
rectángulo pues iba a tener esta base
pero su altura no va estar dada ni por
la función evaluada aquí ni acá sino en
el punto medio
en este punto medio de acá y cuánto vale
cuanto vale este punto medio
pues es la mitad entre x0 y x1 o sea
sería x0 más x1 entre 2
entonces la altura la tratamos así vemos
hasta dónde llegamos este punto de acá
este punto de acá es f de x0 más x1
entre 2 y por tanto el rectángulo se
verían se vería más o menos así
a iván y que me quede un poco más como
rectángulo entonces ahí tendríamos el
primer rectángulo va el rectángulo
número uno de modo similar aquí
tomaríamos el punto medio subimos
llegamos hasta la función evaluada ahí y
esta sería la altura del rectángulo
número dos y está aquí es la altura del
rectángulo número dos y continuamos
continuamos hasta el enésimo rectángulo
donde una vez más pues tiene esta base
verdad x n 1 x n pero ahora la altura
llega aquí va a la función evaluada en
el punto medio entonces llega aquí
salehí vale este de aquí sería el
enésimo rectángulo como nos quedaría la
aproximación pues ahora quedaría la suma
la suma
desde iu igual a uno hasta n y ahora
como está dada la altura pues ahora
tenemos que evaluar la función en el
punto medio en el punto medio de el
punto xy menos uno y el punto equis y en
el punto medio y eso lo tenemos que
multiplicar por delta x la misma delta x
esta delta x no ha cambiado es venosa /
n que también es la misma del delta x
acá pero la diferencia es que estamos
evaluando la función f en el punto medio
muy bien ya tenemos tres formas de
hacerlo vamos a pensar en una más pero
vamos a ponernos un poco más creativos
ahora vamos a cambiar de figura
geométrica y vamos a utilizar trapecios
vale trapecios eso suena más divertido
entonces cómo le haríamos para calcular
el este el área pues teníamos que
dibujar nuestros trapecios los trapecios
van a ser así uno de los lados va a ser
efe en el extremo izquierdo y el otro
lado va a ser
efe en el extremo derecho un extremo
final entonces el trapecio se vería más
o menos algo así va esto de aquí sería
el trapecio número uno
el segundo trapecio ahora iría de aquí
y este punto de acá éste sería el de la
presión número 2 y así seguimos y
seguimos hasta acá
hasta acá que tendríamos el enésimo
trapecio uno de los lados es el fx n 1 y
el otro es fx y esos son los lados
paralelos este es el enésimo trapecio
muy bien cómo le hacemos para calcular
el área de este trapecio pues vamos a
acordarnos cómo se calcula el área de un
trapecio en general vale entonces mira
este punto de acá es efe x 1
y este punto de acá es fx2 entre x2 y
para calcular el área de un trapecio
tenemos que promediar sus lados
paralelos y multiplicar por la distancia
que los separa entonces por ejemplo para
este primer trapecio este que voy a
sombrear su área sería promediar sus dos
lados sería efe de x 1 +
efe x 2 flt x 2 dividido entre 2 desde
el promedio de los lados y hay que
multiplicarlo por la distancia que los
separa en este caso sería delta de x muy
bien este es el área del primer trapecio
verdad nada más estoy acá entonces como
le haríamos para obtener nuestra
aproximación pues sumamos todas las
áreas y por lo tanto nos quedaría la
suma
la suma desde y igual a 1 hasta n
entonces hay que promediar los dos
valores de la función la de f x y bueno
le voy a poner aquí primero xy menos uno
más
efe de x
dividido entre 2 entre 2 y todo eso voy
a moverme tantito a la derecha x delta x
el mismísimo delta x de siempre sale
vale entonces quería mostrarte de estas
cuatro formas para acostumbrarnos a que
hay varias formas en las cuales podemos
aproximar el área por debajo de una
integral estás puedes verla puede que
las veas en tus libros y de hecho puede
ser que veas estos símbolos de acá que
parecen símbolos algebraicos sin mucho
sentido entonces lo que quiero que te
quede además de las cuatro formas de
hacerlo es que estos símbolos
algebraicos representan algo en el fondo
representan una aproximación utilizando
rectángulos o trapecios este es con el
extremo izquierdo verdad con la altura
dada por el extremo izquierdo está con
la altura dada por el extremo derecho
está con el punto medio y estar acá es
una aproximación utilizando trapecios